Mass Effect Andromeda is barely awake
away from being in your clutches and
bioware have released some brand new
gameplay footage to whet your appetite
during a pax east panel this week
Bioware showed off the loyalty mission
for one of your new squad mates am the
new video features quite a bit of combat
and shows what will happen if you get
yourself killed if you're worried about
story spoilers probably best to skip
this one massive extry didn't have
loyalty missions so it's nice to see one
of the best features of mass effect 2
making a return in Andromeda if you
didn't play mass effect 2 loyalty
missions are designed to flush out the
backstory of your squad mates with each
character getting their own you can
unlock them by showing an interest in
your companions or just progressing the
story the missions give you a chance to
get to know more about your companion ad
ultimately increase your bond with them
by completing their respective missions
creative director Mac Walters said as a
writer one of the things I loved was the
freedom to say I know this character is
coming along so they can carry a lot of
narrative that made my job easier but it
also made it more fun because I could
tell a more specific story in one of
those missions for more andromeda
features and gameplay be sure to hit
that subscribe button and stay tuned to
gamespot
[Music]